Ariana Grande and Pete Davidson make it
Instagram official AGT is back and Mel B
is already moved to tears plus new
couple alert Nick Jonas and Priyanka
Chopra hello friends I'm Danny director
with another dose of the daily den now
Memorial Day was the unofficial start to
summer which means our favorite summer
TV show is back and no I'm not talking
about the Bachelorette I'm talking about
America's Got Talent
the competition show kicked off last
night and here's the thing is there any
other show besides like this is us that
tugs at the heartstrings like a GT does
I know I can't be alone in that feeling
but if you need some more proof look no
further than the brother-sister singing
trio we three whose original song about
their mother who died of cancer moved
the audience including judge Mel bees
[Music]
it's just simple with me but eyes elite
you guys I didn't get to watch that back
until I was at work today so that's now
two times I've cried at my desk but
anyway it was really beautiful and they
are moving on in the competition of
course but there were also some happy
tears last night every year the judges
and host Tyra Banks get to send one act
straight to the live shows with the
golden buzzer the first one of the
season happened last night courtesy of
acrobatic dance troupe soukara
but who has been the most
[Applause]
okay let's go
I am collecting my breath and I just I
need some oxygen right now this is brain
this is burst this is Herman today this
is me
I'm such a sucker you guys now do you
love this show as much as I do because
I've been covering this show for a
couple years now and it gets me every
time we'll be covering a GT all season
long so stick around for that and maybe
I'm in a sappy mood but there's a new
celeb couple who just made an Instagram
official and I'm like be still my heart
did you guys see this SNL's Pete
Davidson posted this cute pic with
rumored girlfriend ariana grande and
with that the Chamber of Secrets has
opened the duo are rocking their best
Harry Potter dragon plot twist Pete
apparently is a Gryffindor and Ariana's
a Slytherin now they may be on the
opposite side of the tracks but don't
they look kind of keep together I'm so
into it I can barely breathe are you
even commented on the pic with some
pointed emojis and a dad joke you trying
to Slytherin et first learned last week
these two are casually dating this after
she split from boyfriend Mac Miller
after dating for two years our source
said the former couple had been on the
rocks for a while
ari herself said it was a toxic
relationship but et's source adds that
ariana is in a very good place and very
happy right now looks like it cuz I
already found herself a fellow
potterhead and he's funny
she actually posted this photo at one of
Pete's can upsets with the heart face
emoji hashtag Instagram official
meanwhile ariana is also getting candid
about her upcoming album sweetener and
how the Manchester Bonnie has affected
her music our he admits to fader she
cried 100 times making this record and
even though she's still going to be
serving us with the bops it's still her
bleeding heart and there's a message
behind it quote there's definitely some
crying on the dance floor stuff on this
one and to that I say sign me all the
way up while Arianna says she's not 100%
healed from the Manchester tragedy she's
now okay with letting her emotions run
free
well then break free re okay I'm done
with the Aria on puns very happy for her
but you know what she's not the only
artist who may be in a new relationship
these days Nick Jonas is sparking rumors
he's dating Priyanka Chopra last year
they turn heads when they walk the red
carpet together at the Met Gala and
according to just Jarrett just this past
weekend they
Beauty and the Beast live in concert at
the Hollywood Bowl and then on Saturday
they were spotted at a Dodgers game
together now an onlooker told ET that
Nick and Priyanka looked very happy as
super smiley at the game and they added
that the parent didn't show any PDA but
we're acting very friendly and couple
like what do you guys think I need to
know they're both beautiful but do you
see them together
you know I'm all about these new hot
romances so I'm curious to hear what you
guys think on that one but that's all
the tea I have for you today so thanks
for watching i'ma head out but we'll be
back tomorrow so subscribe follow you
know the deal